[Music]  how hot do you like your courage Susan I  didn't really are seriously how a they  are now lady out no that's good news  because one of our diners over there  okay claims he makes the hottest curry  in the country yes  is that right we've come that's right  going up came over from Newcastle right  Alan are you man enough to try drew  comes curry  I love it right here we go now I've  heard okay is the hotties in the country  so take the smallest amount possible  okay now don't go crazy a small amount  okay tiny tiny amount seriously  [Applause]  [Music]  oh my do that a nice brooch on that is  [ __ ] yeah this thing is worse than  disgusting there's a hottest thing I've  ever tasted  oh my god right okay  oh my god that is shocking